there are a lot of different things that
have happened in the last few years that
have inspired the concept of this album
I was really grateful to get the chance
to sing a new song innocent on the VMAs
and that really falls under the same
theme of the entire record of just
saying exactly how you feel when the
moment is right Taylor Swift getting
candid then and now she's telling all
sorts of stories in the four different
versions of her lover Diaries and we've
got all the teeth I'm really happy for
you I'm going to finish first up a full
entry right after that VM a moment she
writes a part quote if you had told me
that one of the biggest stars in the
world was going to jump on stage and
announce that he thought I shouldn't
have won on live television I would have
said that stuff doesn't really happen in
real life well apparently it does it's
case by case she also writes about the
stress she experienced writing the album
that followed Speak Now quote I'm
borderline losing it she says she was
growing tired of the songs because she
knew she could do better and added I've
been silent about so much that I'm
saying on this album
it's time to speak now and remember the
whole Kimye snake situation the camera
crew filmed him speaking to Taylor and
got their whole conversation Taylor
simply wrote in August of 2016 quote
this summer is the apocalypse Taylor is
very candid about her insecurities
throughout all the Diaries in an entry
from November 2006 when she was just 16
she says she's quote dieting again quote
I didn't watch what I ate and man it's
so weird how fast I can gain or lose
weight it's crazy so I'm going to lose
some now in 2009 she wrote about reading
self-help books and in 2010 she wrote
about her stage fright adding criticism
of my performances has been the biggest
source of pain in my life in a 2003
entry she opens up about strangers
showing up to her house quote they could
never imagine how much that feels like
you hunted but there's also some fun
starstruck memories in there she recalls
being invited to the Met Gala in 2008
and says quote I saw every celebrity
ever created Scarlett Johansson Gisele
Tom Brady Beyonce Jon Bon Jovi who
called me over to talk to him Victoria
Beckham Tom Cruise and Katie Holmes
everyone add another point she briefly
mentions Justin Timberlake and how funny
he is in several entries she opens up
about her rise to stardom and reveals
Capitol Records basically turned her
down she also talks about signing with
Big Machine Records and how she loved
how passionate Scott Borchetta was and
of course there's a ton of references to
her personal life in a March 2009 entry
she joked said it's her fate to roll her
eyes at happy couples in 2014 she
contemplates moving to New York and then
says quote dating is awful love is
fiction a myth
I'm over at all we also get a 2017 entry
about none other than Jo Alwyn quote I'm
essentially living in London hiding out
trying to protect us from the nasty
world that just wants to ruin things we
have been together and no one has found
out for three months the diaries are
filled with all sorts of other fun facts
and stories and Taylor also reveals the
original lyrics to some of her biggest
songs like all too well
her new album lover is out now